a beloved four-legged friend famous
across the valley for his love of the
golden knights has died
ayton is now reporter Brian will tells
us how fans are reacting to the news of
bark Andre furry's passing
it is with a heavy heart that Rick
Williams owner of beloved Sports loving
therapy dog bark Andre furry confirms
his passing fans here at City National
were shocked about the news it's
devastating as sad it's
um hopefully he'll be up there in in
puppy heaven watching down on us and and
uh and just leading the guys to another
Victory he would show up at night's
practices Comfort children at Summerlin
Hospital and draw a huge following on
social media
his quirky name was inspired by Mark
Andre Fleury the team's first big star
bark Andre Fury fell ill last November
with cataracts and liver complications
the 14 year old Jack Russell Terrier was
put to rest on June 2nd it hits
different because like you know it's
man's best friend you two have like fun
with each other and you make memories
and it's kind of like a best friend just
leaving out of nowhere or like a family
member just passing away so it sucks
when a dog's eyes and especially if he
has like a big platform furry's biggest
impact was as an ambassador at the Tyler
Robinson Foundation which was started by
Las Vegas band Imagine Dragons and
Tyler's family to help battle Childhood
Cancer he was seen all over the valley
and I saw him a couple of times here at
City National when his owner brought him
by and I got to Penn him a few times so
it's very sad news to hear he was like
the original Knights puppy you know and
and he was there for for everything the
night today
wow that's that's sad a legacy that will
live on with these fans going let's go
in puppy talk ruff ruff fans here
conveying their condolences for furry
and saying now the knights are playing
for him reporting in Summerlin Brian
will eight news now
he was wonderful now Bark's owner tells
Brian that he's thankful for all the
messages of love and support and to make
sure fans know that bark is always
cheering on the golden knights